[موسيقى]
حوار دار قبل عده سنوات بين طبيب اسنان
امريكي واحد مرضاه بانتظار تفاعل المخدر
مع اسنانه ساله عن هواياته فاجاب المريض
القراءه احب القراءه وم تقرا في هذه
الايام يا صديقي فرد عليه اقرا عن دوله
اسرائيل فقال له الطبيب متهكما اذا انت من
هواه قراءه القصص القصيره الى
العناوين العاروري شهيدا بقصف استهدفه في
ضاحيه بيروت
الجنوبيه صحيفه ريتس اسرائيل وقعت في فخ
استراتيجي
جندي احتياط يقول ان ثلاجته فارغه من
الطعام فمن
يعوض الشهيد الساجد تيسير ابو طعميه داعيه
من كتيبه حفظه
القران مستشفيات اسرائيل العقليه تعلن
حاله الطوارئ في صفوف
الجيش يتباهى بقتل طفله ويتحسر على عدم
عثوره على رضع
حهم نتنياهو حرب اسرائيل ضد غزه لا مثيل
لعدل
واخلاقها شيخ يحرم الجهاد في فلسطين وضابط
امريكي يدعو لتدمير
اسرائيل تسجيل مسلمين جدد تاثرا بصبر
الفلسطينيين وهذه المره في
لندن اولا يجب ان نؤكد بشكل قاطع ونهائي
انه دمائنا وارواحنا ليست اغلى ولا اعز من
اي
شهيد اولا واخيرا ولا يجوز لام شهيد ان
تشعر انه دماء القائد ولل المسؤول اعز
واغلى من دماء ابنها
ا سواسيه احنا والشهيد الذي سبقنا بيوم
افضل منا افضل منه مرحبا فشلوا في تصفيه
قيادات المقاومه في غزه م ممد الضيف يحيى
السنوار واخرين فذهبوا الى بيروت واغتالوا
الشيخ صالح العاروري نائب رئيس حركه
المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس التي اعتادت على
تشييع صفها الاول الى مثوى الشهاده صالح
العاروري كان اسيرا تم تحريره والان تحرر
من دنيا الظلم بعدما ادى واجبه الديني
والوطني تجاه بلده فلسطين بحسب ما جاء في
بعض عبارات نعيه الشعبي علما ان الدقه في
استهداف المكتب الذي كان فيه في ضاحيه
بيروت الجنوبيه يفضح تعمد اسرائيل قتل
الاطفال والمدنيين في مذبحتي المفتوحه
بغزه بكل الاحوال الشهيد العاروري ليس
اغلى من اي شهيد فلسطيني اخر كما قال
العاروري نفسه في واحده من اخر مق
مقابلاته التلفزيونيه في الضاحيه الجنوبيه
ببيروت استشهد نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي
لحركه حماس صالح العاروري وقياديين بكتائب
القسام قبل معركه طوفان الاقصى في السابع
من اكتوبر الماضي بعده اشهر بدا الاهتمام
الاسرائيلي بتصفيه صالح العاروري حيث يراه
مسؤولون اسرائيليون مسؤولا عن محاولات
لاشعال ما قالوا انها شراره انتفاضه جديده
في الضفه الغربيه عام
1966 ولد الصالح محمد سليمان العاروري في
قريه عروره برام الله وحصل على بكالوريوس
في الشريعه الاسلاميه من جامعه الخليل
ساهم العاروري في تاسيس كتائب عز الدين
القسام الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس في
الضفه الغربيه ويعد احد ابرز الرؤوس
المدبره لتسليح اعتقل صالح العاروري اكثر
من 18 سنه في السجون الاسرائيليه وعندما
افرج عنه في المره الاخيره عام 2010 ابعد
خارج فلسطين واختير عضوا في المكتب
السياسي لحركه حماس ثم لرئيس المكتب
السياسي للحركه في اكتوبر
2017 كان العاروري احد اعضاء الفريق
المفاوض لاتمام صفقه شاليط المعروفه بوفاء
الاحرار والتي تمت عام
2011 في الحدي من اكتوبر الماضي فجرت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منزل عائله صالح
العاروري بعد اسابيع من بدء الحرب الحاليه
ياتي استشهاد العاروري في سياق تهديدات
اسرائيليه متواليه باستهداف قاده حماس
بالداخل والخارج لكن وقوع العمل يه في
الضاحيه الجنوبيه في بيروت قد يدخل بالحرب
الراهنه في منعطفات جديده وخطيره والده
الشهيد العاروري السيده عائشه تصريحاتها
عقب استشهاد ابنها لا تنتمي الى هذا الزمن
بل تتصل بزمن الخنساء كما علق الراصدون
لما يموت الواحد موت شريف احسن من
شليش الحمد
لله شو بتحكي خالتي اليوم
سمعك شو بتحكي خالتي شو بتحكي اليوم اليوم
استشهد ابنك الله يرحمه صالح شو بتحبي
[موسيقى]
تحكي احسن احسن فرحه
هي ليش نعيط يعني هو بتمنى في هالموت زمان
بكل شي الاصحابي توفوا
ماتوا استشهدوا وانا
ظليت ظليت تاخرت انا يعني مالش زمان
قلمها وحابب يستشهد اه والحمد
لله
بنقوله انا لله وانا اليه راجعون اخته
بتقول اخوي صالح
استشهد الله يرحمه ياما نه هذا مسعد وت
شفعنا ويشفع 7 من اهله شو بنا احسن من
هالموت اه والحمد اللي احنا راضيين بهالشي
ما حدا تخلد على ظاهر ه الدنيا اه كلنا
رايحين عبر العالم الى سنه جديده مثقلا
بعقيده الاقصاء التي تترسخ في الغرب
والشرق المتسابقين على التطوير النوعي
للاسلحه النوويه
والاثنا وسط اصوات وازنه حول العالم لا
تنفك تحذر من تثليث الحروب
العالميه وما ظلمناهم ولكن كانوا انفسهم
يظلمون صدق الله العظيم اما في فلسطين
فالزمن توقف منذ العام
1948 عندما قرر المنتصرون في الحرب
العالميه الهمجيه سرقه فلسطين واقامه دوله
اقلو عنصريه على ارضها
ثلاثه اشهر اختتمت بها اسرائيل سنتها بمحر
تتعامل فيها مع اطفال غزه وكانهم احفاد
هتلر سنه قاسيه اعلى الغزيين تطوى صفحتها
وقد لا تمحى ماسيه من الذاكره الجمعيه
للفلسطينيين يابع من اجبع
من هو الحصاد المر لعام غير مسبوق على
الفلسطينيين حصدت فيه اله الحرب
الاسرائيليه ارواح ما يزيد على 21 الف شخص
مخلفه اكثر من 56 الف مصاب ويخشى ان يكون
الالاف قد لقوا حتفهم تحت انقاض البنايات
المدمره جبوره المتصهين العربي الافتراضي
لا يرى ان اسرائيل قابله للهزيمه بل هي
مشروع قائم الى يوم القيامه في مقابل من
تقول الدراسات انهم اغلبيه عربيه واسلاميه
تؤمن بحتم زوال اسرائيل وبعضهم يستعجل
الامر كما عبر هذا الفنان
الالكتروني يقول احد الحكماء لا تستصغر
احدا فالصغير يكبر والضعيف يقوى وتقول
صحيفه هارتس العبريه ان اسرائيل لم تتمتع
بالحكمه عندما اعلنت الحرب المفتوحه على
غزه بل هي وقعت في فخ استراتيجي عندما
اساءت تقدير قوه المقاومه الفلسطينيه
تقرير لصحيفه ارتس الاسرائيليه يفصل في
ملامح ما يصفه بانه معضله وفخ استراتيجي
وقعت فيه اسرائيل منذ هجمات السابع من
اكتوبر وربما قبل ذلك تقول الصحيفه ان
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين صغر قوه حماس
بينما اغفلت المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
الاسرائيليه التهديد الذي تشكله الحركه
فضلا عن الخطط الهجوميه والدفاعيه التي
كان يعد لها مقاتلو حماس ضد الجيش
الاسرائيلي وتشدد ها ارت على الحاجه
للحفاظ على مخزونات الاسلحه لاحتمال تطور
حرب مكثفه مع حزب الله في الشمال جندي
احتلال يعتبر انه مرسل من عند الله لانقاذ
رفاقه الذين وصفهم بالملائكه لكنه وجده
جثثا هامده وانار
شللت بشع
ل
هم عائد من غزه يبتز حكومته فيقول ان
ثلاجته في البيت فارغه لانه ترك العمل من
اجل الدفاع عن اسرائيل لقد تم استدعاؤ الى
الخدمه فاسرع
للتلبانى العمل انها كارثه لا اعرف كيف
سانهي يومي الثلاجه فارغه لم احصل حتى على
شيكل واحد انا اخاطر بحياتي واحمي هل هناك
اي شخص اخر ثلاجته فارغه في غزه الجميع
شاريع شهداء من شيخ المقاومه احمد ياسين
قبل سنوات الى وزير الاوقاف وخطيب الاقصى
السابق الشيخ يوسف سلامه هذا الاسبوع
اعلنت وكاله الانباء الفلسطينيه استشهاد
وزير الاوقاف والشؤون الدينيه الاسبق
وخطيب المسجد الاقصى يوسف سلامه في غاره
للاحتلال على منزله في مخيم المغازي وسط
قطاع غزه هذا الشاب يتعثر بدراجته
الهوائيه ليس لثقل حموله سلتها بل لمن
فيها من كوكبه روح الروح فهو اب يضع جثمان
طفله الشهيد في سله الدراجه ويبحث عن مكان
ليدفنه فيه اما الجد الحزين فذهب الى
السوق لشراء جوارب لحفيده الجميل فعاد بها
وقد ذهب حفيده الى حيث يذهب الاطفال
الشهداء لب
الجنه ان شاء
الله وهذا الطفل الرضيع الجريح جود يبكي
طلبا لحضن والدته المفقود فهو لا يعلم
انها اصبحت مع جميع خالاته في عداد
الشهداء هذا الطفل جود كل يوم وعهد الحال
طفل بطالب وجود والدته لكن
ما بيعرف انها استشهدت استشهدت برفقه
اربعه من خالاته قصف اسرائيل على منزلهم
نعم هذا الطفل عمره سنتين اتيتم فقد ولدته
في هذا العمر هذا هو حال الاطفال
فيع ماذا تتوقع اسرائيل ان يصبح جود عندما
سيكبر جبوره لا والله مينيموم سيكون تيسير
ابو طعميه براي عالم اجتماع تيسير ابو
طعميه مقاوم من كتائب القسام اصيب قبل
ايام بشظايا صاروخ اسرائيلي استهدفه في
خان يونس فاختار الشهيد ان يكون اخر عهده
في هذه الدنيا سجده شكر لله على اكرامه
بالشهاده في سبيله الفيديو صورته طائره
اسرائيليه من الجو ونشره اعلام جيش
الاحتلال متباهيا فانقلب عليه وقيده موقع
يوتيوب الذي نبث هذه الحلقه عليه حصرا انا
لاحظت فيديو لم لم يعرض اصابه احد
المقاتلين
بنتيجه قصف وجرح في ظهره واستطاع ان يكابر
على المه وينهي حياته ساجدا بين يدي الله
فيقال ان مصدره الجيش الاحتلال وبالتالي
سيندم انه نش شره لماذا لانه كان كان اجمل
من اج من اجمل الحالات التي تم التعبير
فيها عن ايمان هذا المقاتل بعقيدته وارضه
وعرضه وانه يدافع عن كرامه امه وليس عن
كرامه قطاع غزه فقط ان المشاهد لاقت
تفاعلا جماهيريا عبر السوشيال ميديا مع
هذا المشهد الماساوي والذي يبرز مدى
الشجاعه في استعداد هؤلاء الشهداء لتقديم
ارواحهم في سبيل الدفاع عن ارضهم وكرامتهم
الشهيد تيسير ابو طعميه او ابو طعميه ليس
مواطنا عاديا بل هو حافظ لكتاب الله واحد
مقاومي كتيبه الحفاظ في القسام كذلك هو
امام مسجد فلسطين في بني سهيله في غزه حيث
كان يعكف على تعليم طلابه علوم القران
الكريم وهذه تلاوه بصوته ان الذين امنوا
عمل الصالحات كانت
لهم كانت لهم
جنات الفردوس
نزلا خالدين فيها لا يبغون
عنها وان تكون
وفاتك مناره لتعلم
الناس الخير والفضل
والحق هذه
كلها صفحات وحروف من سطر هذا الشهيد
المجهول عندنا المعلوم عند الله ربما في
الايام القادمه نسمع معلومات عنه لكن الى
الان كل هذه ما يهمنا هو ما تعلمناه من
هذا الشخص يسال الباحثون الاجتماعيون
الغربيون قبل غيرهم اي نوع من الشباب
هؤلاء الذين اختاروا المقاومه على الخيانه
والصبر على التمرد والفداء على الجشع من
يقف على اعدادهم وتنشئتهم
الداعيه الاسلامي محمد راتب النابلسي لديه
كلام في هذا الخصوص ان رايت شابا نظيفا
انيقا صادقا اخلاقيا
متفوقا معنى ذلك ان وراءه ام عظيمه الله
هنيئا لكل ام بهذا الكلام في مقابل الشغف
الفلسطيني بالشهاده يفكر جنود اسرائيليون
جديا بالانتحار بدلا من مواجهه المقاومه
وانتظار رصاصاته
القاتله مستشفيات اسرائيل العقليه تعلن
حاله الطوارئ لمعالجه الجنود العائدين من
غزه واهاليهم الارتفاع المضطرد في اعداد
الجنود الذين يعانون من اضطرابات نفسيه
اضافه الى الميل الى الانتحار الذي سجل في
حالات كثيره لدى الجنود وشريحه من السكان
الاسرائيليين دفع مستشفيات الامراض الع
عقليه الى اعلان حاله الطوارئ صحيفه يدعوت
احرونوت نقلت عن وزاره الصحه الاسرائيليه
تسجيل ارتفاع كبير في ميول الانتحار
والامراض العقليه الخطيره في صفوف الجنود
اصبح الجندي الاسرائيلي لا يامن على حياته
في الثكنه العسكريه من زملائه ليس لانهم
يكرهونه حرام ما في شي شخصي لكنها هستيريا
او قل غزه فوبيا حقيقه هم يقاتلون افا قد
لا يرونها ياتي مقاتل فلسطيني من حيث لا
تراه اعينهم فيلق قنبله تقتل رتلا عسكريا
اسرائيليا اما من نجى منهم فيسقط في
مستنقع الهواجس والكوابيس التي تجعله
فريسه للمرض النفسي القصص كثيره عن المرض
النفسي الذي يضرب بقسوه جنود اسرائيل
واشهرها الجني الذي استيقظ على كابوس بعد
ايام من عودته من غزه مما ادى الى
استخدامه البندقيه ضد رفاقه من الجيش وظل
يطلق النار على جدار غرفته جنود يدخلون
غزه فلا يخرجون الا بذكرى ترافقهم مدى
حياتهم او على شواهد
قبورهم ما هو هدف جيش الاحتلال من مواصله
نشر فيديوهات السطو الديني على بيوت
الفلسطينيين ومساجدهم حيث يحولونها الى
مراكز عسكريه وكنس يهوديه يؤدون فيها
طقوسهم على ارض
مغتصبه
شكاك عاملون مع المسلمين وكانهم هم من
احرقوا اليهود في اوروبا فهل يقرا شيئا عن
تاريخ اجدادهم ليعرفوا ان المسلمين حموه
وانقذهم من الذبح
والاضطهاد والكلام للحاخام
اليهودي الحنان
بيك so even you have to with us if not
you will be killed completely false
everybody knows a bit the
history we have a golden life in the
muslim countries we persecuted in places
the world and the muslims sav us they
giv us a golden place to there everybody
knows the history knows the muslim world
of
october of october
قتل النفس البريئه هو قمه الاجرام وقمه
القمه ان يقتل القاتل طفلا اما من يقتل
طفله ويتباهى بقتلها ويعلن عن غضبه لانه
لم يعثر على اطفال رضع
ليذبح فهذا لا تعريف له في القواميس الا
انه
اسرائيلي فهنيئا لارشيف تلبيب هذا الاجرام
قدس الذي ترد عليه امريكيه يهوديه مناهضه
لاسرائيل
بطريقتها
الساخره
is
ام لجندي احتلال دافني اتى من فرنسا
ليقاتل ويقتل في غزه تقطر حنانا وامومه
فتصدر الى تلبيب بالقاء القنبله النوويه
على غزه حتى لا يبقى في فلسطين الا اليهود
تقول فما راي قيم الجمهوريه الفرنسيه
بموقف
مواطنتها علما ان النائب الفرنسي دافيد
توعدها بالمقا في محاكم
باريس
acpp le nous qu nous somes
uncom vo
habit
terre hab terre n'est ju بعد كل هذه
الاستعراضات الاجراميه الهتلريه الحيه
نتنياهو لا يقنع بالكذب الصغيره فيقول ان
حرب اسرائيل ضد غزه لا مثيل للها
واخلاقها فما هي الاعدادات الموجوده في
عقل نتنياهو وصف رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو حرب لاده ضد غزه بال
الدفاعيه مشيرا الى انه لا مثيل لعدل
واخلاقياتها مضيفا ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يتصرف باكبر قدر ممكن من الاخلاقيات في
قطاع غزه حسب تعبيره رئيس حكومه دافن دوله
اسرائيل من الفرات للنيل نتنياهو كان يرد
على رفع دوله جنوب افريقيا الدعوه امام
المحكمه الدوليه ضد اسرائيل فاصبحت في
نظره دوله ارهابيه
وربما داعشيه وقالت المحكمه في بيان لها
ان جنوب افريقيا اكدت ان افعال اسرائيل في
القطاع تحمل طابع اباده وتعد انتهاكا
لالتزاماتها بموجب ميثاق الامم المتحده
داعيه الى محاسبتها على ذلك في المقابل
رفضت تلبيب دعوى جنوب افريقيا لانها لا
تستند الى اساس قانوني واتهمتها بالتعاون
مع جماعه ارهابيه تدعو الى تدمير اسرائيل
وفق وصفها رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي السابق
دان حالوتس يقول انه لن يكون هناك نصر
لاسرائيل الا
بالاطاحة وغيرها من معدات الجيش فهل يطيح
محمد الضيف بنتنياهو الذي يواصل سحب
وتبديل الويه جيشه في
غزه
شنل
تمون
200 بسبب عدم تكافؤ القوى يرى احد المشايخ
ان الجهاد الراهن في فلسطين هو جهاد في
سبيل الشيطان اما الضابط الامريكي السابق
سكوت رايتر فيحيي مقاومه حماس ويدعو الى
اسرائيل التي اصبحت برايه امه من المجرمين
بدعم امريكي لما يكون الجهاد تستباح
البيضات وتنتهك الاعراض وتقهر قلوب صدور
المؤمنين هذا ليس بجهاد هذا جهاد في سبيل
الشيطان
is ام شهيد فلسطيني لا تريد اعضاء ابنها
تعيش في اجساد
الاسرائيليين مع تاكيد وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه تسلمها بعض جثامين الشهداء وقد
سرقت منها بعض الاعضاء انا ام ما بدي حاجه
من ابني تروح انا ابني سلمولي اياه زي ما
كان وكيف تتجر اسرائيل ان تاخذ من اعضاء
من اعضاء اولادنا لانهم هدول شهداء شهداء
وبدنا اياهم ما بدناش اي حاجه من اعضاء من
اولادنا تتاخذ لانه هذا عدونا وين حقوق
الانسان وين حد بده يحاكمهم مين ان سلوك
واجرام المحتل الاسرائيلي يجعل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لديه القدره على التمثيل
بالشهداء وسرقه
رغم كل الاحداث الماساويه في قطاع غزه
والتي يحمل البعض حركه حماس المسؤوليه
عنها ترتفع شعبيه حماس عند الشعب
الفلسطيني وتنخفض شعبيه الرئيس عباس بحسب
تقرير للتلفزيون الالماني بعد ثلاثه اشهر
من الحرب في غزه ازدادت كثيرا شعبيه حماس
المصنفه منظمه ارهابيه من قبل الاتحاد
الاوروبي والولايات
المتحده في سبتمبر الماضي ايد حماس 12% في
الضفه الغربيه و
38% في قطاع غزه وارتفع في ديسمبر ل 44%
في الضفه و 42% في القطاع كما يظهر
الاستطلاع ان محمود عباس رئيس السلطه
الفلسطينيه التي تحكم الضفه الغربيه رسميا
لا يؤيده الا
11% حتى الاطفال الذين يحلمون بمدرستهم
والملعب وثياب العيد لا يريدون اي يذهب مع
توني بلير الى اي تهجير جديد رغم نفيه
انخراطه في هذا المشروع الى اي مكان باقو
في فلسطين واحنا الدور الجاي اذا صارت في
حد كمان انا مش نازحه من غزه انا عن جد مش
حطلع من غزه اضلني في غزه ولو قصفوا
البيوت اللي عننا قصفوا البيوت راح
نبنيه ورا نسكن فيهم لانه انا
غزويه وانا دائما مواطنه اضلني في غزه مش
مبسوطه انا من غير ابويا انا لو رجع ابويا
جنبي وضل معي فانا ببسم وبضحك من كل قلبي
اذا كان ما يجري ليس
تهجيراً وانيابه طائرات
امريكيه دعوا مقرره الامم المتحده في
فلسطين ترو رؤيتها
and
gaz
وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي لا يكذب مقرره
الامم المتحده بل يصادق على كلامها فزه
جميله وعلينا ان نطرد الفلسطينيين منها
يقول طيب مونتي كارلو شواطئها
وفيها كازينوهات جاهزه سموتريتش المعروف
بتصريحاته المتطرفه قال في مقابله مع
القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه ان غزه
لن تظل مرتعا لمليوني شخص يريدون تدمير
دوله اسرائيل ويتعين على تل ابيب ايجاد
البلدان التي ترغب في استقبال سكان غزه
ارادو حمله اعلاميه لتشويه الاسلام فتحولت
الى دعوه للاسلام هكذا يعلق شيخ ازهري على
قوافل الذين يشهرون اسلامهم تاثرا بمبدا
الصبر والاحتساب عند الله في غزه في لندن
ثمانيه مسلمين جدد من اصل عشره ذكروا ان
سبب اعتناقهم الاسلام هم الفلسطينيون
الذين يتعرضون لعدوان اسرائيلي في قطاع
غزه وفق القائمين على مسجد لويشام
بالعاصمه البريطانيه الناس خسرت اولادها
واطفالها و وبيوتها وكل شيء كل شيء خسره
بس الحمد لله لسه عننا امل مقاطع الفيديو
المتداوله لصبر اهالي غزه على مصابهم اذهل
الغربيين وجعلهم يفكرون بقوه الايمان
الهائله التي تمدهم بالسكينه وتجعلهم
يحمدون الله عند فقد احبتهم وهدم منازلهم
يقال ان
الفيتناميين بنوا مدارس لابنائهم تحت
الارض اثناء الغزو الامريكي اما في فلسطين
فالتعليم فوق الارض وتحت خطر تساقط صواريخ
الاحتلال صوره لمدرس غزي يجوب مراكز
النازحين لتدريس الاطفال تضاف الى البوم
الصمود في فلسطين والرعب من المستقبل في
اسرائيل طبعا ارق كبير بين دوامنا المعتاد
في السابق في مدرستي اللي كنت ادرس فيها
الطلاب وما بين هذه المدرسه اللي اصبحت
مركز للنازحين في بدايه دوام كنت اشاهد
دائما طابور الصباح طابور الطلاب المنصه
والاذاعه الدراسيه والمعلمين والزملاء
الان اصبحنا نشاهد سكان داخل الصفوف ملابس
منشوره على الدرابزين انا ما كنت اتوقع
انه الحرب حتستمر لانه لدرجه انه نروح على
مدارس احنا هينا اليوم كنا نروح على
المدرسه ندرس هلا صرنا نروح على المدرسه
نصوف دور عشان نعبي مي واكل اخيرا لم زهره
جميله في غزه كل اهلها ونحن ايضا في فريق
البرنامج نقول لها بيلبق لك تكوني صحفيه
يا لما بابا وماما واخواتي كانوا يحكوا
لي صوري مع نفسك تكون صحفيه انا بحب اصور
فيديوهات على الانستغرام بحب انزل
فيديوهات على الحارب وبحب
انه بدي اوصل رسالتي للعالم كله انه
يوقفوا الحرب عنا وعن اطفال فلسطيني اللي
هم تعذبوا
وبجوع
[موسيقى]
كمان ختاما عندما هبطت طائره الرئيس
المصري الراحل انور السادات في تل ابيب
وبدا بمصافحه مستقبليه الرسميين وصل الدور
الى جولدا مائير وكانت في حينه رئيسه
حكومه سابقه نظر اليها السادات بابتسامته
الملغومه وقال لها اتعرفين ماذا يقولون
عنك يا سيده مائير في مصر فردت جلده بن
دهاش كلا وماذا يقولون يا سياده الرئيس
فاخبرها السادات انهم يقولون انك اجدع
راجل اقوى رجل في اسرائيل والى الان لم
يختطف اللقب من جولدا رجل في اسرائيل حتى
باعتراف وون نفسه الى اللقاء جولد مائير
ام اسرائيل الحديثه اخطر امراه في تاريخ
الكيان الصهيوني وصفها بن جوريون بانها
الرجل الوحيد في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
لدرجه ان تم وصفها بالرجل الوحيد في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وام اسرائيل الحديثه
ماما ده ايه يا اخويا هتقلب عل المواجع
يعني هو احنا فعلا بنقول اسرائيل ما فيهاش
رجاله بس مش للدرجه
دي
[موسيقى]
ه